a story that has gripped the Colombians
since this plane crashed on the 1st of
May they had been traveling in a small
single-engine aircraft and there were
seven passengers on board the pilot
declared an emergency because that
single engine had failed and the plane
fell off radon that's when the search
began for these children when the plane
was found about two weeks later
um the adult bodies were found nearby
but the children were nowhere to be seen
so they stepped up their search sensing
that these children could still be alive
and they found some Clues so tiny little
Footprints they found pieces of fruit
that had been sort of half eaten by
humans and they found nappies so that
gave them a sense now the four children
were aged 13 9 4 and just 11 months so
the youngest was just 11 months old now
during the search Rescuers used things
like flares the helicopters dropped
boxes of food hoping that the children
might find them and help to sustain them
and this part is my favorite they used
speakers to blame messages from the
children's Grandma telling them to stay
in the same place because this is a very
dense forest you can see from the
pictures how dense it is it's very
difficult for ground teams but also
helicopters to see anything now there's
a bit of Hope on around May 18th when
the president tweeted that the children
had been found where he later deleted
that tweet and said that he had been
disinformed that children are from the
wyoto tribe and they're you know Keen
survivors they're known to survive
forests so there was lots of Hope going
through this have a listen to what the
president Gustavo Petro said
the first news is that indeed the
indigenous communities participating in
the search along with the Colombian
military have found the four children
after 40 days they were alone it was
them who achieved a great exemplary
survival
it will become history these children
are today the Children of Peace and the
children of Colombia
so it is an incredible story a very
happy story to wake up to on a Saturday
morning but it's worth remembering that
these children have been through a lot
of trauma they would have seen adults
being killed in a plane crash it's a
really traumatic thing so they're now
being treated in hospital but it is a
remarkable Story of Survival